[Music]
only two years ago the physical capacity
for the euro was a purely academic
endeavor last night after 11 hours of
negotiations we turned it into reality
in the form of a budgetary instrument
for the euro area the so-called big we
have a new pillar in the Foundation's
supporting the euro at about midnight
ministers agreed on all the critical
elements of governance and financing
which make big an innovative tool
different from other EU funds as a
starting point we expect the big to make
use of the euro area share of the
financial envelope originally proposed
by the Commission for the reform
delivery tool leaders will decide the
amount in the context of the EU budget
to provide scope to go beyond this
envelope we will introduce a so called
enabling clause in the relevant
regulation to do so we will need an
intergovernmental agreement a 98 this
mention is not the end of the issue but
it could be a new beginning in terms of
resources we agreed on a separate
standalone instrument for countries that
have not yet adopted the Europe this is
the convergence and reform instrument
you